I won't lie when I got my tickets to
this early screening I had to stifle a
squeal of joy
Lincoln is directed by Steven Spielberg
one of my favorite directors one of the
best directors ever he's made so many
classics I don't even have to say
anything about him he's Steven Spielberg
goodness sakes and it starts Daniel
day-lewis one of the best actors of our
time and it's a true story about Abraham
Lincoln one of the best presidents we've
ever had so this movie has a lot going
for it and has a huge fan of movies I
was obviously excited for this movie to
see those levels of talent on display it
also stars Sally Field as Abraham
Lincoln's wife Tommy Lee Jones James
Spader David Strathairn lots of people
in this movie the movie is largely about
the days leading up to when Lincoln
would try to pass the Thirteenth
Amendment and how he went through that
ordeal how he was trying to abolish
slavery how other people were opposing
him and not just the historical aspect
of it but moreso also what was going on
with his family and how he had to take
care of his kids and his wife still and
all the pressures that were basically on
him and how he dealt with that and it's
not a movie with a lot of you know
action set-pieces or whatnot there's one
action set piece in this film this is a
talking movie okay this is a talkie
movie you're going to go into this movie
and it's going to be lots and lots of
dialogue and lots and lots and lots of
more dialogue this is not your typical
Spielberg film he's never made a movie
like this this is very very meditative
very quiet and I found very compelling
Daniel day-lewis is fantastic in this
movie he embodies everything that
Abraham Lincoln in my mind ever was the
look I mean for goodness sakes if he
showed someone a picture of Daniel
day-lewis as Lincoln you know who didn't
know about this movie or that actor
anything might be like wow that's a
really high-quality picture of Abraham
Lincoln good Wow where did you find that
thing that's probably worth a lot of
money spielberg directs this movie very
restrained he doesn't get in the way of
these performances he pans in on Lewis
slowly you know he lets the camera sift
through the crowd as Lewis is giving his
speeches you feel that Spielberg has a
really great grasp on this story and on
this character I did a lot of research
about this movie Spielberg actually
studied Abraham Lincoln for 12 years
before making this movie 12 years he
studied about Lincoln that is some
serious dedication and it always annoys
me lately because I see a lot of younger
people today hating on Spielberg and I
don't know
why there are a few directors who put
that much effort into their films and he
deserves credit for that the pocket
watch that Daniel day-lewis looks at in
this movie the sound effect of that
ticking is actually the actual sound of
Abraham Lincoln's
actual watch that they recorded from the
museum that is holding his actual watch
today
that is some serious dedication to this
movie and I was impressed by that
whenever a movie has basically nothing
but dialogue the dialogue has to be
compelling and it has to be told in a
way that's interesting and for me
Lincoln really did a good job of doing
that the movie was actually really funny
too it had a lot of good humor in it but
it wasn't like overriding over the story
it was just right and it really gave the
movie more of a heartfelt feel but not
in a sappy way or a cliched way it
actually worked a lot for the film I
thought now the biggest surprise of this
movie for me was not just that Daniel
day-lewis his performance in my opinion
is oscar-worthy
but Tommy Lee Jones in this movie gives
one of the best performances that I've
ever seen from him I couldn't wait for
his character to get back on the screen
because not only was it a really
entertaining character with a lot of
really good dialogue but you understood
him really well in the way that his
character arcs eventually is extremely
profound like I was like you're gotta be
kidding me like that was just it was so
beautiful movie has problems it does and
really the only things that bug me were
a slight section in the middle because
as I said when a movie is basically just
dialogue it has to be really good and it
has to be really interesting and there
was maybe like a 10 to 15 minute section
in the middle of the film that I was a
little bored by and that's just because
it seemed like a lot of it was standard
procedure we have to get through this
part of the story to get to the next
more meaty part of the story and I
understand that but it did drag a film
down a little bit Joseph gordon-levitt
is also good in the film he's not ended
a whole lot but the scenes he has he's
very good at Sally Field was good in the
movie everyone was good in this film
because Spielberg is an actor's director
he understands how to direct a film he's
good with all the technical aspects of
it obviously but he also loves working
with actors and that's why a lot of his
actors always give such good
performances in his movies and the
spielberg does a thing that I love so
much in movies nowadays a lot of times
directors they like to cut back and
forth between actors as I talked back
and forth cut to this guy cut to that
girl Spielberg does that sometimes too
but he's also a fan of just panning out
for the entire scene and maybe just
moving the camera ever so slightly as
all of the
ders in the frame are acting to the best
of their ability like a play like a
stage play because no actor can go while
I'm not in a close-up right now so I
don't have to act as hard as I usually
do because they're all in shock it gets
the best performances out of actors and
Spielberg understands that Lincoln is a
movie that I was really invested in it
was a film that I thought was really
well told I really enjoyed the film it
has magnificent performances to
oscar-worthy ones and in my opinion it's
Spielberg's best film since Munich in
2005 I'm gonna give Lincoln an a- i
really suggest seeing this film when it
comes out especially if you're a film
fan or if you're an aspiring director in
any way or you like acting i mean it's
basically a master class and all of
these things on film but just know that
it's a talking movie you know you're not
going to go in this movie and be like Oh
for like two hours it's a talking movie
and enjoy it for what it is thanks a lot
for watching guys and as always if you
like this then you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]